why doesn't the earth trust the moon
because the moon never reveals its dark
side the moon has a side which no one
can ever see from the earth which is
called the dark side or the far side
let's find out why we know that the moon
rotates about its axis and revolves
around the earth but how does this
really happen for better understanding
let's mark the side which can be seen by
the earth in a different color now many
of us imagine the moon's movement to be
happening like this rotating about its
axis and revolving around the earth
notice that here the moon is completing
many rotations before it completes one
complete revolution but that's not how
it works which brings us to the most
important concept here the time taken by
the moon to rotate about its axis once
it's almost the same as the time it
takes to revolve around the earth once
both approximately 27 days this gives us
the answer here's what actually happens
in this time period
notice that the moon is revolving around
the earth
and rotating about its axis as well
after about half the time period the
moon is here and the earth has only seen
the near side and the moon continues to
do so for the remaining time period and
hence the revolution back at the same
point where it started in this same time
period of around 27 days it rotated once
about its axis and revolved once around
the Earth swirl
let's have a look at this one more time
notice how the moon is moving we can see
that at any point in time just one side
of the moon is visible to us from Earth
in reality the earth is rotating as well
as revolving around the Sun but
irrespective of that from any point on
the earth only one side of the moon can
be seen so now we know why the earth
doesn't trust the moon but what about
the earth and the Sun it's the same
concept applicable for them as well no
right we note that the earth completes
one revolution around the Sun in
approximately 365 days and what about
its rotation is that also 365 days nope
we're aware that its rotation time is 1
day or 24 hours so it's clear now that
from the Sun both the sides of the earth
would be visible but what if at some
point in the future Earth's rotation
time equals its revolution time what do
you think would this result in if this
happens we know that only one side of
the earth will be exposed to the Sun
while the other side will forever be in
darkness what will its implications be
how different would our life be on earth
then well it's a cue box to explore
share your thoughts in the comment
section below also do subscribe to the
channel to keep learning and exploring